i'm here with editor
in chief of my favorite the best the
most successful magazine people it's dan
wakeford
thank you for having me
all right dan it's your story what do we
not have got an adorable mini royal in
the uk and this is a story we covered at
people on our stories to make you smile
paige and it really made me smile
one-year-old jolane sutherland dressed
up as the queen for halloween and she
posed with her best friends her corgis
and people reported that her mum katie
sent the photo to the queen on a whim
and she couldn't quite believe it she
got a royal response on official windsor
castle stationary the queen says she was
pleased to see the photo and thought
jolene's outfit was in quotes splendid
do you think that the corgis in the
picture really sent her over the edge
because she's like the biggest corgi
lover i mean it's all about the it's all
about the little girl not the corgis oh
look at that little girl her she mimics
the queen so well she's got this naughty
little glint in her eye and the naughty
smile like the queen has i love it i
know i just love that she responded
because i think the queen is a prg
genius she knows when to be quiet when
to speak out and it really shows that
she has a great sense of humor that she
responded to this yeah i know this is
that picture in particular
she almost looks more like the queen
like facially in in this picture i love
this story okay well next up we've got
some research on the topic of love shape
recently asked the question how long
does it take to fall in love well love
researcher helen fisher says it varies
of course you can fall love at first
sight or it can be a slow burn but
what's the average so one study found
for men it took about three months into
a relationship to want to say
i love you
but women took about five months to want
to say
i love you
and of course feeling like you love
someone can happen a lot sooner than
when you actually tell them
now dan how was it for you and your
husband what was your personal
experience well it certainly was lust at
first night anyway
but
um i think i'm like the survey it was
exactly three months my husband's a lot
younger than me he's a lot cooler and a
lot more emotionally mature but i think
i was the first person to say that i
loved him but like i think you've got to
be careful you can fall in you can think
you're falling in love before but it's
all chemistry and hormones and sex and
it clouds you and it tricks you and i
think you it takes three months of you
experiencing them and seeing them on a
bad day seeing them stressed and tired
to really make sure that you are in love
with someone so for me it was exactly as
a study said three months i feel like i
also can like
fall really quickly and be like oh my
god i'm so into this person i can't stop
thinking about them i'm so in but then i
also fall out in and in that's why
you've got to wait three months that's
why you've got to see them properly and
really feel it and i think the survey
picks up on something that they don't
say immediately and i think women are
more cautious and they're aware of that
and that's why they're taking their time
to make sure that they are sure
and then in a relationship like okay if
that's the statue of limitations on the
average of maybe what it takes to say i
love you what do you think it is to be
with someone before you really know
or think you know them
i mean i think people grow and they
change so you're always getting to
really know them know them so i think i
think that is an interesting question
for me i felt i knew him to his heart
after three months
and i still learning new things to this
day the fact he doesn't put the cups but
away properly in the dishwasher
well i think the truth is there are no
rules be open-minded be open-hearted and
adventurous and
love is the north star
that's all i know
yeah i love you dan this has been thank
you for having me
please come back whenever you like is it
okay to know
far before three months that you want a
second date
let's have a second day okay good then
we'll be right back thank you dan
wakeberg
by the way pick up the latest issue of
people on newsstands right now
[Music]
you